Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速告诉大家一件正在发生的令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“迈向经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Hi, today on the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, I am guiding you through my seven top
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有由Lisa本人直接提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目。大家好，欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家》播客，今天我将带大家了解我的七大
tips for how to cope with waiting lists and reserve lists in psychology and mental health jobs. Stay right to the end to soak up all my advice and guidance. I hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. You might well know that I've got a social media presence. I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. and today's episode was a special request from somebody on my socials. Today we are thinking about that exquisite hell which is a waiting list or a reserve list. This usually crops up when it comes to doctoral training courses but also might well happen in undergraduate or master's study. And it's possible that it happens in relevant experience roles too. And today I am offering my advice and guidance on how to navigate being on a waiting list. Now, in case you're not sure
应对心理学和心理健康工作中候补名单和预备名单的建议。请坚持听到最后，吸收我所有的建议和指导。希望你觉得这些内容很有用。你好，欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是Marianne Trent博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。你可能知道我在社交媒体上很活跃，到处都是Dr. Marianne Trent。今天的节目是根据社交媒体上某位听众的特别要求制作的。今天我们来探讨那个令人煎熬的“地狱”——候补名单或预备名单。这种情况通常出现在博士培训课程中，但也可能发生在本科或硕士学习期间。而且，它也可能发生在相关的工作岗位申请中。今天，我将提供关于如何应对候补名单的建议和指导。现在，如果你不确定
what I mean when I say reserve list or waiting list, let me explain. So, for example, in clinical psychology, there might be 25 places available for the doctoral program, but they will usually see probably about 75 to 80, maybe even 100 people at interview for those posts. Now the people that they feel are not appointable will likely be sent a thanks, but no thanks. But the people that they feel are of the standard and the calibre that they would want to be having within their programme of study might well be offered a reserve list place. So that's what we're talking about today. People that have essentially made the grade, but they're waiting
我所说的“预备名单”或“候补名单”是什么意思，让我来解释一下。例如，在临床心理学中，博士课程可能有25个名额，但他们通常会面试大约75到80人，甚至100人。那些他们认为不适合录用的人通常会收到一封礼貌的拒绝信。但那些他们认为达到标准和水平、希望招入课程的人，可能会被列入预备名单。这就是我们今天讨论的内容。这些人基本上已经达到了标准，但正在等待
for people to be able to either be interviewed elsewhere and then decline their place that they've been offered, which then bumps everybody up the waiting list, or, you know, for them to decide to then accept that waiting list place, which then, you know, doesn't change your position on the waiting list. So in today's episode, I'm going to be guiding you through my seven areas of consideration for this. But firstly, before I do that, let me tell you about my own experience of waiting lists. For the course that I ended up studying with I was offered one of the 15 places outright but for the course that I was also offered I was first reserve. Now not everybody gets given a number these days for what position you are on the list. But if you do have a number and you end up as first reserve, it's usually almost possibly guaranteed that you might well be getting an
其他人去别处面试并拒绝了已获得的录取通知，这会使名单上的每个人排名上升；或者，他们决定接受那个候补名额，这当然不会改变你在名单上的位置。所以在今天的节目中，我将引导你了解关于此事的七个考量点。但首先，在开始之前，让我告诉你我自己的候补名单经历。对于我最终就读的课程，我直接获得了15个名额中的一个，但对于另一门我也获得录取的课程，我是第一候补。现在，并不是每个人都能在名单上获得具体的排名。但如果你确实有一个排名，并且最终成为第一候补，通常几乎可以保证你可能会得到一个
offer. Because of course, a cohort of up to 40-ish plus people, it's likely that some people are being offered multiple course offers and that, you know, the one that you've been offered might not be their first choice, either for geographical reasons or, you know, personal reasons or just because they don't like the course as much as the one that they are going to accept. So there's a number of reasons why people might wait. And of course, what we know certainly about the doctorate in clinical psychology is that there's an interview season that starts in March and ends in May. And they try very carefully not to overlap too much geographically. And of course, if you were having interviews, it's possible that you might well have an interview in the first week of interviews in March.
录取通知。因为当然，一个大约40人左右的群体，很可能有些人会收到多个课程的录取通知，而你收到的那个可能不是他们的首选，无论是出于地理原因、个人原因，还是仅仅因为他们不喜欢这门课程胜过他们打算接受的那一门。所以人们等待的原因有很多。当然，我们肯定知道临床心理学博士课程的面试季从3月开始，到5月结束。他们非常小心地避免在地理位置上重叠太多。当然，如果你参加面试，你很可能在3月的第一周就有面试。
And you might still have interviews in the last weeks in May. And so your application, your interview season might well be very well spread out so you might have been offered a place from the first set of interviews that you did in March or April or even May but then you are holding out hope or you just want to consider your options and then you might well be offered a place places later in the season as well and you just just want to be super well informed and to get a feel for that course, how it makes you feel and, you know, whether you would want to do a programme of study there. And so you absolutely don't have to make your mind up. I did an episode recently, which is episode 74, that you might also want to check out.
而你可能在5月的最后几周还有面试。所以你的申请和面试季可能会拉得很长，你可能在3月、4月甚至5月参加的第一轮面试中就获得了录取，但你还在抱有希望，或者只是想考虑一下你的选择，然后你可能会在季末获得其他录取。你只是想获得充分的信息，感受一下那门课程，它给你的感觉如何，以及你是否想在那里学习。所以你绝对不必急于做决定。我最近做了一期节目，即第74期，你可能也想去听听。
And that was about, well, should you still go to interviews if you've been offered a place elsewhere? So you might find that useful as well. And of course, another reason that I forgot to include in that podcast episode is that you might want to go and see how your performance compares. You know, once you know you've got a course offer, you might want to go and just feel a bit more at peace and at ease, and it might feel that you're more able to be just yourself and to really bring your arousal levels back down to a more comfortable yellow window of tolerance zone
那期节目是关于“如果你已经在别处获得了录取，是否还应该去参加面试”。你可能会觉得那期节目也很有用。当然，我在那期播客中忘记提到的另一个原因是，你可能想去看看自己的表现如何。你知道，一旦你知道自己有了课程录取，你可能想去感受一下，让自己更平静、更从容，你可能会觉得更能做回自己，并真正将你的唤醒水平降回到一个更舒适的“黄色容忍窗口”区域，
of functioning and that's okay you know you've been offered those interviews it is your choice if you wish to accept the interviews or not anyway that's a whole nother podcast episode today we are thinking about how to cope with reserveless places. Because, of course, it does somewhat hold you in limbo. So it holds you in limbo until you know the outcome of interviews, which has to happen by the 2nd of June 2023 for the declineside process. And people need to have responded by the 9th of June 2023. So hopefully you should know either way I guess by the week after the 9th of June. But of course that said I have heard of people being offered places on training in you know late August and September as people's circumstances change across the summer
这没关系。你知道，你已经获得了那些面试机会，是否接受面试是你的选择。总之，那是另一期播客的内容了。今天我们是在思考如何应对预备名单。因为，当然，这确实会让你处于一种悬而未决的状态。它让你处于悬而未决的状态，直到你知道面试结果，这必须在2023年6月2日之前完成（针对拒绝流程）。人们需要在2023年6月9日之前做出回应。所以希望你在6月9日之后的那一周就能知道结果。但话虽如此，我确实听说过有人在8月底和9月才收到培训录取通知，因为人们的情况在整个夏天发生了变化。
this is a whole lot easier to manage if you know the numbers if you know for example that you are number 30 on the reserve list and there's only 22 places it's possibly looking less likely that you'll be offered a place that year. But I know some courses have moved to not giving numbers, which adds more layers of, you know, anxiety, I think, and feeling very distracted, discombobulated, not really knowing, you know, which basket to put your apples in. Because if you know, you know, you're number one or two, three, four, five, then you think, oh, okay, this could be happening. But if you're number 60, I don't know how high some of the course lists go with their reserve lists, then it's possibly unlikely. So let me start guiding you through our top tips and considerations for how
如果你知道具体数字，这会容易管理得多。例如，如果你知道你在预备名单上排名第30，而只有22个名额，那么你当年获得录取的可能性可能较小。但我知道有些课程已经不再提供排名，我认为这增加了更多的焦虑感，让人感到非常分心、不知所措，真的不知道该把鸡蛋放在哪个篮子里。因为如果你知道你是第一、二、三、四或五名，你会想，哦，好吧，这可能会发生。但如果你是第60名，我不知道有些课程的预备名单有多长，那么这可能不太可能。所以让我开始引导你了解我们应对这个难题的建议和考量。
to tackle this beast. So if I was in your position on a waiting list, I would, I guess, try to be thinking about my mindset. And I'm not gonna be gaslighting myself with false promise necessarily. But you know, I do like the idea of a little bit of manifestation. And so I'd be doing some compassionate flows out there into the world to let this opportunity come to me. What is the worst that can happen with doing that? Granted, you might feel a little bit silly when you begin to do that, but I promise you that over time that will ease and it feels like you're doing something, you know, to help control this situation that might well feel uncontrollable. And as part of this tip, it's important to remember that, of course, you are of the appropriate calibre to be offered this opportunity. And so you need to really take something from that. You know, for example,
所以，如果我处于你这样的候补名单位置，我想我会尝试调整我的心态。我不会用虚假的承诺来欺骗自己。但你知道，我确实喜欢一点点“显化”的想法。所以我会向世界发出一些慈悲的能量，让这个机会来到我身边。这样做最坏的结果是什么呢？诚然，当你开始这样做时，你可能会觉得有点傻，但我向你保证，随着时间的推移，这种感觉会减轻，而且这让你觉得自己在做些什么来帮助控制这种可能感觉无法控制的情况。作为这个建议的一部分，重要的是要记住，当然，你具备获得这个机会的相应能力。所以你真的需要从中获得一些东西。例如，
if it is a trainee psychologist role, then you know that you are of the right standard, you are saying the right things, you are doing the right things, you're presenting yourself in the right way to be offered that role. And you've got to feel really proud of yourself for that. Consideration number two. So number two is about potentially seeking feedback so you know whilst technically they may not tell you what number you are on the reserve lists i've been known to you know to make friends with people on um admin departments and see what you can find out so seeking feedback about your performance in the interview can be useful to know what it is that you know that went really well even though you were successful you're
如果这是一个实习心理学家职位，那么你知道你达到了正确的标准，你在说正确的话，你在做正确的事，你以正确的方式展示了自己，从而获得了那个职位。你必须为此感到非常自豪。考量点二。所以第二点是关于潜在地寻求反馈。虽然从技术上讲，他们可能不会告诉你你在预备名单上的排名，但我曾有过与行政部门的人交朋友并看看能打听到什么的经历。所以，寻求关于面试表现的反馈，了解即使你成功进入了预备名单，哪些方面做得很好，也是有用的。
on a reserve list it can be useful to get a little bit more clarification about what might have helped you score more points to get you across the line but yeah if you can it's really useful to get the number that you're at just so that you can manage your own expectations accordingly, really. It can also be useful, even if they won't tell you how many places are left on the reserve list, to ask them maybe how many people are still waiting to confirm places. So if there's only one or two out of a cohort of 40, 40 plus, then it might be less likely. But if actually out of a cohort that size, they're still waiting for 15 or 20 people to confirm, then you know, you can help manage your expectations in that way. Consideration number three is all about the power of your network, other people's network and networking. How can you connect with people
了解什么可能有助于你获得更多分数以跨过门槛，这可能很有用。但如果可以的话，获得你的排名确实非常有用，这样你就可以相应地管理自己的期望。即使他们不告诉你预备名单上还剩多少名额，询问他们还有多少人正在等待确认名额也可能很有用。如果40多人中只有一两个名额，那么可能性可能较小。但如果实际上在那个规模的群体中，他们还在等待15或20人确认，那么你就可以通过这种方式来管理你的期望。考量点三是关于你的人脉、他人的网络以及社交的力量。你如何与人建立联系，
either in person or perhaps on social media to, you know, to feel validated, to feel like you're understood and to think about how you might be able to benefit from the skills and the wisdom of other people who get it and might perhaps be the next stage ahead of you in your career. It might involve going to conferences, professional events, meetings, anything you can think of or find to continue to increase your exposure to people in your area of specialty, but also those who might be able to help enrich your knowledge, understanding and how supported you feel along the way. And that has been a really nice and unexpected feature of the Aspiring Psychologist membership because the community are so wonderful in rallying together and supporting one another
无论是面对面还是在社交媒体上，去感受被认可，去感受被理解，并思考如何从那些了解情况的人的技能和智慧中受益，他们可能在职业生涯中比你领先一步。这可能涉及参加会议、专业活动、聚会，任何你能想到或找到的方法，以继续增加你在专业领域接触他人的机会，同时也包括那些能够帮助丰富你的知识、理解以及让你在过程中感到被支持的人。这一直是《有抱负的心理学家》会员计划中一个非常美好且出乎意料的特色，因为社区成员在团结一致、互相支持方面非常棒，
and helping celebrate wins, but also helping to kind of process any complex or complicated feelings which might come up. So if you are missing people that feel like your tribe at the moment, you might well consider joining the Aspiring Psychologist membership. And this leads us nicely into consideration number four. So I always think that if you're on a reserve list, it can be useful to think about it possibly as being a no and thinking about what you need to do to be able to get yourself in a position that the next time there's jobs up, that you are given an outright yes rather than a maybe. And so how can you look at your strengths and weaknesses profile to think about what might need padding out what might need thickening you know enhancing reducing your Achilles heel for that
不仅帮助庆祝胜利，还帮助处理可能出现的任何复杂或纠结的情绪。所以，如果你现在觉得缺少像你一样的群体，你可能需要考虑加入《有抱负的心理学家》会员计划。这很好地引出了考量点四。我总是认为，如果你在预备名单上，把它看作是一个“不”可能是有用的，并思考你需要做什么才能让自己在下次有职位空缺时，获得一个直接的“是”而不是“也许”。所以，你如何审视自己的优势和劣势，思考什么需要补充、什么需要加强，你知道，增强或减少你在该领域的短板。
area so it might well be that you want to focus on online training or in-person training events that you want to immerse yourself in the literature and the research in the areas that you want to work in ultimately. If you're an aspiring clinical psychologist it might well be that you'd like to attend workshops with qualified professionals to help advance your skills and your confidence and of course that will always benefit you if you do end up getting that reserve list place as well. And please do know that when you get on from a reserve list place, it's just a place, you know, it's no different. You are a member of the cohort and you deserve to be there.
所以你可能想专注于在线培训或面对面培训活动，你可能想沉浸在你最终想从事的领域的文献和研究中。如果你是一名有抱负的临床心理学家，你可能想参加合格专业人士的研讨会，以帮助提升你的技能和信心。当然，如果你最终确实获得了那个预备名单名额，这也会对你有好处。请务必知道，当你从预备名单中获得名额时，那只是一个名额，你知道，没有什么不同。你是该群体的一员，你理应在那里。
So this chance to upskill and thicken this narrative can be really important in helping you both now to feel like you're getting that control back, but also in future if it doesn't work out, this opportunity that you are going to be in a stronger position next time around. And again, this is something aspiring psychologist membership is really, really good at. If you'd like information about how to join, please do check out the information in the description if you're watching on YouTube or in the show notes if you're listening on audio. Now it's a really nice opportunity to play a little jingle for one of the books and I will catch you on the other side for our next three of our seven considerations. If you're enjoying the content, please do like
所以，这个提升技能和充实经历的机会对于帮助你现在感到重新获得控制感非常重要，而且在未来如果这次没成功，这个机会也会让你在下次处于更有利的地位。同样，这也是《有抱负的心理学家》会员计划非常擅长的事情。如果你想了解如何加入的信息，如果你在YouTube上观看，请查看描述中的信息；如果你在听音频，请查看节目说明。现在是一个播放书籍宣传短片的绝佳机会，我会在下一部分回来，继续我们七个考量点中的后三个。如果你喜欢这些内容，请点赞
and subscribe and drop a comment in for me too see you very soon Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Welcome back. So in the first half, we were thinking about four of our top seven considerations for how to manage the sweet hell that can be being on reserve lists for training or job opportunities. Let's crash straight on with number five. So number five is all about expanding your search and broadening your horizons. It might well be that you start to look at other
并订阅，也给我留个言。很快再见。充满经验和教训，将帮助你获得资格。所以来看看吧。就在这本书里。它是《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。它是《临床心理学家合集》。欢迎回来。在前半部分，我们思考了管理培训或工作机会预备名单这种“甜蜜地狱”的七大考量点中的四个。让我们直接进入第五点。第五点是关于扩大你的搜索范围和拓宽你的视野。可能不仅仅只有一种方式可以成为合格的心理学家。
opportunities out there. So for example, there's not only one way to get qualified as a psychologist. It might be that you are able to look at whether counselling psychology might be a good fit for you, or whether, for example, as Anagashama and I explored together in episode 57 of the podcast, there was the little known way to get qualified as a clinical psychologist is to do the dual discipline and do forensic psychology as well. Now, these are, of course, self-funded routes, but it's worth just exploring what that would look like and how you might be able to either get that funded from an employer or how you might be able to afford other self-funding options. It might be that you use this time to think about maybe potentially applying for other
例如，你可能能够看看咨询心理学是否适合你，或者，例如，正如Anagashama和我在播客第57期中共同探讨的那样，成为临床心理学家的一个鲜为人知的途径是进行双学科学习，同时也学习法医心理学。当然，这些是自费途径，但值得探索一下那会是什么样子，以及你如何能够从雇主那里获得资助，或者你如何能够负担得起其他自费选项。你可能利用这段时间考虑申请其他
relevant roles which might help strengthen your chances the next time around in case these reserve list places don't work out. That might look like applying for other assistant psychology roles, it might look like applying for a master psychology roles. It might look like applying for a master's. It could look like doing some additional skills or qualification. It could look like doing some additional skills training in a particular area that you want to strengthen. For example, on CBT or working with specific populations, or using specific approaches. And again, this is something that we really excel at in the Aspiring Psychologist membership. And people might be like, oh, well, should I be applying for jobs if I might be letting them down at the last minute? But
相关职位，这可能有助于在这些预备名单名额没成功的情况下，加强你下次的机会。这可能看起来像是申请其他心理学助理职位，或者申请硕士心理学职位。这可能看起来像是申请硕士学位。这可能看起来像是学习一些额外的技能或资格。这可能看起来像是进行特定领域的额外技能培训，你想加强这些领域。例如，关于CBT或与特定人群合作，或使用特定的方法。同样，这也是我们在《有抱负的心理学家》会员计划中非常擅长的。人们可能会问，如果我可能会在最后一刻让雇主失望，我是否应该申请工作？但
you've got to look after yourself. It's okay to do that. It's okay to put your own needs first. And of course, employers understand that people's okay to put your own needs first and of course employers understand that people's positions will change all of the time for a variety of reasons so perhaps you're working in children's services and you've never worked with people with intellectual disabilities or perhaps you're working in intellectual disabilities you've never worked with older adults you've never worked with working age adults it's okay to think about what opportunities there might be around at this time to help strengthen your abilities. And of course, this time of year is a good time to be looking for jobs because as people get on clinical training, sometimes people
你必须照顾好自己。这样做没关系。把自己的需求放在首位没关系。当然，雇主也理解人们的情况会因为各种原因随时发生变化。所以也许你在儿童服务部门工作，从未与智力障碍人士合作过；或者也许你在智力障碍部门工作，从未与老年人或工作年龄的成年人合作过。思考一下此时此刻有哪些机会可以帮助加强你的能力是没关系的。当然，每年的这个时候是找工作的好时机，因为当人们获得临床培训机会时，有时人们
resign right away once they've got their unconditional offer because they want to spend the summer doing something different. And so yeah yeah this is a potentially exciting time for the job market over the next few months. So consideration number six is just staying focused, staying persistent, staying enthusiastic, staying polite as you go about your inquiries about what position you are on the list. You know, they will, of course, understand the level of anxiety that you might be experiencing because it does make a big difference. You know, if somebody is potentially preparing to move from London to Scotland, for example, that's not something that should be done without planning
一旦拿到无条件录取通知就会立即辞职，因为他们想花夏天做点别的事情。所以，是的，这在未来几个月对就业市场来说是一个潜在的激动人心的时刻。所以考量点六是保持专注、保持坚持、保持热情、保持礼貌，当你询问自己在名单上的位置时。你知道，他们当然会理解你可能正在经历的焦虑程度，因为这确实有很大的不同。你知道，如果有人可能正准备从伦敦搬到苏格兰，例如，那不是在没有计划
and without consideration. So they will understand, you know, what this means to you. And hopefully they will be kind to you in their interactions with you too. Consideration number seven is last but not least, it's managing your own expectations. So it would have been preferable for you to be given an outright place of course it would but it might not happen for you this year and that is going to evoke lots of complicated feelings it might make you feel quite sad you know quite rejected even that you're not good enough that you're not measuring up, that others are better. And all of those thoughts and feelings are really normal. But we also need to be thinking
和没有考虑的情况下应该做的事情。所以他们会理解这对你意味着什么。希望他们在与你的互动中也能对你友善。考量点七是最后但同样重要的一点，即管理你自己的期望。当然，如果能直接获得名额会更好，但今年可能不会发生，这会引发许多复杂的情绪。这可能会让你感到非常难过，你知道，甚至感到被拒绝，觉得你不够好，你没有达到标准，别人比你更好。所有这些想法和感受都是非常正常的。
about letting our compassionate other help us through this. There's not a lot of good that comes from self-criticism. So you might well want to plan something that you know is going to be a real celebration of where you're at right now. So if you think it's unlikely that you'll get onto training this year then could you go and have a lovely holiday in September, October or at some point during that year which might have been trickier for you to do if you were doing this job or training offer that you might well not be offered how can you use this time really wonderfully so it might be that you want to use this time to really celebrate your life where you're at right now it might involve getting married it might involve moving house you know it's about knowing that where you're at right now is, you know, it's okay to feel happy and content there
但我们也需要考虑让我们的“慈悲自我”帮助我们度过难关。自我批评并不会带来什么好处。所以你可能想计划一些你知道会真正庆祝你现在所处位置的事情。所以，如果你认为今年不太可能进入培训，那么你能在9月、10月或那一年的某个时候去度个愉快的假吗？如果你正在做这份工作或培训，而你可能没有获得录取，这可能对你来说会更棘手。你如何能真正美妙地利用这段时间？所以你可能想利用这段时间真正庆祝你的生活，庆祝你现在所处的位置。这可能涉及结婚，可能涉及搬家。你知道，这是关于知道你现在所处的位置，你知道，在那里感到快乐和满足是没关系的，
and to grow roots and spread your wings and you just see what happens next time around. So just in summary, our top seven considerations were staying positive and proactive, seeking feedback if possible, continual networking, enhancing your skills, expanding your search, staying updated and persistent, and last but not least, managing your expectations. I hope you found it useful. Please know that I feel for you this is really difficult, especially if you're potentially you know looking to move somewhere with yourself or your family your pets and you're just waiting to hear I know that this you know this is your life and it matters please do stay kind to yourself if you found this content useful please do like comment engage, rate and review if listening on Spotify or Apple. I love providing
并扎根和展翅高飞，看看下次会发生什么。总之，我们的七大考量点是：保持积极和主动、尽可能寻求反馈、持续建立人脉、提升技能、扩大搜索范围、保持更新和坚持，最后但同样重要的是，管理你的期望。希望你觉得这些很有用。请知道我为你感到难过，这真的很困难，特别是如果你可能正打算带着自己或家人、宠物搬到某个地方，而你只是在等待消息。我知道这是你的生活，它很重要。请务必对自己友善。如果你觉得这些内容有用，请点赞、评论、参与、评分并在Spotify或Apple上留下评论。我喜欢提供
this content for you and I love that you think it's helpful. If you'd like to tip me for the work that I do, you can see links in my social media bio. If you tend to listen by going to my website www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast for every episode there is now a donate button as well thank you so much for being part of my world please do stay kind to yourself and if you could recommend the podcast to others you think might find it useful I'd be so grateful thank you so much I'll look forward to delivering you the next episode which is available from 6am on Monday. Take care. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner.
这些内容给你，我也很高兴你觉得它有帮助。如果你想为我的工作打赏，你可以在我的社交媒体简介中看到链接。如果你倾向于通过访问我的网站www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcast来收听，每一集现在都有一个捐赠按钮。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。请务必对自己友善，如果你能向其他人推荐你认为有用的播客，我会非常感激。非常感谢，我期待着为你带来下一集，该集将于周一早上6点发布。保重。《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Jana，我是一名心理健康实习从业者。
I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。成为临床心理学家的途径之多让我感到惊讶，没有完美的途径可以成为一名心理学家，这让我充满了信心，不再觉得我做错了，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你感到安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就不会放下这本书。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。